il
les maisons de ville
la réunion le terme emplacement désigne
le lieu où s'élève une maison et ses
dépendances
les maisons de vie sont systématiquement
entouré de murs de clôture on y accède
par un barreau terme local désignant le
portail d'entrée
la succession des barreaux et des murs
d'enceinte dans les centres anciens des
villes est l'un des éléments les plus
caractéristiques de l'urbanisme
réunionnais ses barreaux market une
rupture symbolique entre l'espace public
de la rue et celui plus intimes des
maisons les portails sont généralement
flanqué de deux grands piliers en moy
l'enduit à la chaux ou en base à se
tailler une fois le barreau franchi le
visiteur accède au jardin d'agrément
inspiré des jardins à la française
sa composition est souvent symétrique de
part et d'autre d'un axe central dans
tous les jardins traditionnels plusieurs
bassins fournissent l'eau destinée à
l'arrosage visible de la rue la maison
est généralement au centre de la
parcelle entre jardins et cours
en effet contrairement aux hôtels
particuliers parisiens des xviie et
xviiie siècles
le jardin se trouve ici côté rue tandis
que la cour se trouve à l'arrière
espace le plus intime de l'emplacement
elle est réservée à la famille on y
trouve la cuisine
les réserves de bois et de nourriture le
logement des domestiques la salle de
bains et les lieux d'aisance en
hiérarchisant les espaces l'emplacement
recréant ville un modèle inspiré de
l'art de vivre à la campagne
aujourd'hui protégé au titre des
monuments historiques la maison carrère
présente encore partiellement cette
organisation spatiale traditionnels